(sonnerie)
- Oui, allô?
- Esther et son mari, Jean Rody,
ne se sont pas vus depuis
ils ont échappé à un kidnapping,
racontent-ils, aprè
ils ont quitté le pays, en 2017.
- Eh bien...
- Jean Rody avait un visa
pour voyager aux États-Unis.rerr
au Canada.
ANANANAN RODY LAINE, demandeur
d'asile
- On a pris le chemin,e.e.e.e.e.
- Le chemin Roxham?
- Bien oui, c'est le chemin
magique, parce qu'en arrivant
tous vos rêves s'étalentvavavavr
réaliser vos rêves. q q q q q qe
de retrouver sa famille
ne s'est pas encore réalisé.
Il a un garçon de 8 ans
et unejajajajajajajajajajajajaj!
- Esther était enceinte
La petite Coralie
a aujourd'hui 4 ans.
- Comment vous allez?, , , , , ,
s'est d'abord réfugiée au Chili,
avant de traverser l'Amérique
centrale pour atteindre,
plus tard, l
Fin septembre, la mère et
les deux enfants ont campé
au Texas, avec des milliers
d'autres migrants d'origin
haïtienne. Ils ont finalement
atteint le Canada le mois
- Quand  r r r r r rendue à
la frontière pour me rejoindre,
on lui a refusé l'entrée,
qualifiée.
- Jean Rody et Frantz André,
du Comité d'action des
croient qu'il y a eu erreur.
FRANTZ ANDRÉ, Comité d'a
des personnes sans statut
- Nous interpellons
q q q q q q q q q q q q q q q n
ministérielle, on le souhaite,
dans les prochains jours,
qu'elle va pouvoir rentrer,
pat t t t t t t t t t t t t t te
et, pour une raison ou
une autre, à la dernière
minute, on lui a dit
- Roxham Road?
- Si.
- Elle veut passer par
le chemin Roxham?
- Ce passage à la frontière
serait une solution de rec
Fermé au début de la pandémie,
il est rouvert depuis
FRANCINE DUPUIS, PDG adj, CIUSSS
Centre-Ouest-de-l'î
- On s'attendait à une hausse
et elle s'est matérialisée.
- Lendndndndndndndndndndndndndnl
n'en recevait pratiquement
plus dans les derniers mois.
Il en arrive maintenant
- Je pense pas que ça va être
un raz-de-marée, mais
je pense que ça va être plus
une ascension progressive,
en Haïti, d'autres pourraient
entreprendreéréréréréréréréripl.
- Ton enfant, je pourrai
dans mes bras.- - - - - - - - Jr
touchent au but.
Ici Sébastien Desrosil.l.l.l.l.